well the current situation in europe
actually is
is is a worry i think you know we can't
afford to be complacent you know we are
facing across the region
actually a huge wave of of omicron which
is now
spreading across the countries of of the
region from west to east um and that is
resulting in very large numbers of
infections um
in the countries of
of europe we had over eight million
cases reported last week a huge number
um and of course we know many of those
uh
are less severe but that did result in
over 20 000 deaths in the past past week
across the countries of europe so this
remains a a serious infection we still
are in a pandemic um and
you know
we do need to still take this seriously
and important to highlight that as this
wave moves further east it's moving into
countries where vaccine uptake in
vulnerable populations is much lower
than in countries such as the uk so
we i think there's still some some rocky
road ahead for uh many countries in in
europe
i wonder if i could put this to you
doctor i did uh mention it to the health
secretary i don't know if you heard him
speaking on the program in the last hour
and he was saying that we it it's
absolutely reasonable to compare kovid
to the flu now would you agree
i don't agree um you know we're not at
that point yet um
omicron sarsko v2 is a different
infection it still can be a very serious
infection in those who
are unprotected those who are
unvaccinated um and you know i'd really
like to
reinforce the message that if
if you're not vaccinated or if you've
not completed your course of vaccination
really important
that that you do get it because it will
protect you against serious
disease against hospitalization against
against death
we are clearly moving into a different
phase of the pandemic you know
we have to sort of celebrate the success
of the vaccine program and
and the role out in many countries and
the protection of the population but
we're still not
yet at the end of the road as far as the
pandemic is concerned